-Our first guest tonight
is a Grammy-nominated musician
and actress. She's hosting
the E! People's Choice Award
which air Sunday, November 15th.
Please welcome back to the sho
Demi Lovato.
How are you, Demi?
-I'm so good. It's great
to see you. How are you?
-I'm doing really well.
And I was happy to hear
that, you know, a lot of peopl
have been using this time
that we're separated from
a lot of friends and famil
to do different things,
and I've heard that self-help,
self-improvement
is one of the ways that you've
been spending your time.
-Yeah. Absolutely. So,
at the beginning of quarantine
I got really into meditation
actually,
and I started meditating more.
It was something that, like,
I had kind of done in the past
but not really made
a lifestyle out of it,
and now I've started meditating.
Like, I-I kind of came up with
this new philosophy
that, like, I'm never bored.
I never have to worry
about being bored
because I can always meditat
no matter where I am
or what I'm doing,
so that's helped me a lot.
And then also just,
like, you know,
building better relationship
with my friends and family
and even my dogs.
Like, getting to walk them
is something
that I didn't get to do
when I was working so much
so this quarantine has bee
a nice little experience
for me to get to know myself
better.
-I'm so glad you've been using
it to such positive effect
I also want to talk about
something you used
your time for.
You wrote a song called
"Commander In Chief"
which is basically sort of
a letter to the president.
How did it come about
that you wanted
to express yourself that way
-Well, I was in the studio
with a few friends of mine
and we were coming up
with concepts,
and we were just thinking,
we were like, "What are some --"
I was thinking about the music
that's out there right now
and I was like,
"Why isn't anyone talking abou
what's happening?"
And, you know,
in the '60s and '70s,
like, when anything politica
would happen,
music was such a key element
to help people process it
and get through it.
So I was like, "You know,
really need to step up my lyrics
and make it about somethin
other than just my life."
And so I started making
more music that is less about me
and more about the broad scope
of what's going on in the world,
and one of the songs
that we came up with
was "Commander In Chief,"
and it was inspired
by P!nk's "Dear Mr. President"
you know, when -- back however
many years ago that came out
And I wanted to do,
like, a newer version.
-That's really, really coo
that you did that.
And then I'm wondering,
because of that
and because of
the sort of perspective
that you show in that song
were you excited on Saturday
Did you get out?
Did you dance in the street,
so to speak?
-So, I was actually in Mexico,
and I was on a meditation
retreat, actually.
And so when I got the news
it was on my way home.
And it was the best news.
I cried. I sobbed.
I mean, it was just
an emotional day overall for me,
because I identify as queer,
and so, for me, having somebod
in the Oval Office
that is supportive of that
meant a lot to me,
and it just, you know,
there's --
I'm also a firm believer
in feeling like
the country will be united
after, you know,
some time goes by,
but I think that
we're on the right path
and, yeah,
I'm very, very excited.
-It definitely --
I think all of Saturday
felt like a meditation retreat
for me.
So I can only imagine
how you felt leaving one
and then getting that news
It was like
double meditation retreat.
-Right. Right.
[ Both laugh ]
-Hey, so, you're hosting
the People's Choice Awards
I mean, obviously, you've,
you know, performed
at high-pressure
situations before,
things like the, you know,
national anthem at a Super Bow
or the Grammys.
How do you feel about this one
Are you feeling any nerves a
all, or is it just excitement?
-I'm pretty excited, you know?
I don't feel like there is
too much at stake.
When it comes to the nationa
anthem at the Super Bowl,
there's a little bit
more pressure...
-Sure, sure.
-...than hosting an awards show,
just because, you know,
if you mess up the lyrics,
then people come after you
as an American.
So, you know, I just --
There's less pressure,
but I'm looking forward to it.
And I am still nervous.
Like, don't get me wrong.
Hosting is not my first
language, so to speak.
So, singing is.
And if you have any tips,
please let me know,
because I know you've done
a ton of hosting yourself,
including this talk show, so -
-Well, the only thing
I'll tell you
is just know that you will d
far better at hosting
than I would do
singing the national anthem.
[ Both laugh ]
-Okay. Thank you.
-Just keep that in mind
at any point
that you feel nervous at all
I think another thing
that'll be nice and in general
watching anything like thi
for people,
is you mentioned the stakes.
It will be --
You know, again,
this is people choosing.
We just had an election,
which is also people choosing,
but it would be nice to watc
people choosing something
that doesn't seem to send us off
in one direction over the other.
-This is up to the people.
And, in fact, this is actually
the awards show
that's always
meant the most to me,
because they are the ones
that get to vote.
They are the ones
casting the decisions.
And it's not up to some academ
that, you know,
is political or whatever.
It's like,
this is up to the people.
And that's what
this year has been about -
you know,
listening to the people,
and finally
we're doing it again,
but it's going to be
less pressure and more fun
-I also want to talk
about the fact
that you were here in 2014
as I mentioned,
and one thing we talked abou
is your belief
in aliens and mermaids.
And at the time, I think
I sort of gave you a hard time
I gave you a hard time, bu
let me tell you something, Demi,
that since 2014, so many
crazy things have happened..
-Mm-hmm.
-...that if I came home,
and a mermaid was in my bathtub,
it would still probably be
the 15th craziest thing
that happened
since we last saw each other
-Right.
-So I just want you to kno
I'm not fully there yet,
but I'm starting to come
to your side of the argument
-Alright. Fine.
You know, baby steps.
I'll take it.
-[ Laughs ]
But we're still feeling strong
You're still very firmly
in the alien-mermaid camp.
-I'm on a different
level of that.
Like, I have made contact.
It is through meditation
and consciousness.
It is like -- If you want
to go deep, we can go deep
but I feel like that's going t
take way more than this segment,
so --
-So, well, you did --
I mean, I don't want to go -
I don't know.
Obviously, we don't
have a ton of time,
but when you say contact durin
meditation, is it more likely --
Just tell us this. Are you
more likely to be contacte
by an alien or a mermaid?
-Well, it depends.
Do you view mermaids
as something completely separate
than an extraterrestrial being
-You know what?
I'm going to defer to you now.
Are they the same?
-They could be,
but we see mermaids as
could be just an
extraterrestrial species
living underneath the wate
which we haven't --
-Oh, my God.
The aliens got to Demi's feed.
This is --
This is a classic --
Oh, my God.
You just got frozen
because you were about
to tell us some Area 51 [bleep
and the government
cut out your feed.
I can't believe it.
-Area 51 is --
[ Speaks indistinctly ] Yes.
[ Both laugh ]
-Demi, it's always lovely
to see you. It really --
I hope it won't be this long
between your next visit.
Have a great time hosting
People's Choice Awards,
and all the best.
-Thank you so much.
Thank you, Seth.